Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und ich sage hallo zur 115.
Sendung und auch diese Folge ist eine Folge in der Serie hier vom CERN,
dem großen Kernforschungsinstitut in der Schweiz könnte man sagen oder auch
in Frankreich, teilweise so, teilweise so.
Das merkt man hier gar nicht, wie man hier durch die Länder kreist und vor allem
die großen Beschleunigerringe, die kümmern sich hier auch überhaupt nicht drumherum.
Hier fliegen einfach die Teilchen von Land zu Land und kümmern sich nicht groß
um die Politik. So soll es sein, denn hier geht es um Wissenschaft.
Und heute ist der nächste Detektor dran. In der letzten Sendung haben wir ja
schon über das CMS gesprochen.
Einer der beiden großen, wichtigen Hauptdetektoren kann man sagen,
die am Large Hadron Collider, dem großen 27 Kilometer Ring,
dranhängen und dort sich in den Teilchenstrom hängen, um alles Mögliche mal
nachzumessen, wie denn das nun eigentlich ist, so wie dieser Physik.
Und jetzt schauen wir uns eben den zweiten an, den Atlas Detektor und um darüber
zu Und zu sprechen begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Christoph Remser. Hallo.
Hallo.
Hallo Christoph, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, ich hab's schon gesagt, also du bist Teil des Atlas Teams,
Leiter seit 2016 glaube ich sogar schon, also eine ganze Weile und vielleicht
sogar noch länger hier, das hören wir gleich.
Mich würde nämlich mal interessieren, wie so dein Weg in die Wissenschaft gewesen ist.
Und wo du dann am Ende hier gelandet bist.
Ja das ist eigentlich eine schöne und tolle Geschichte. Ich bin immer,
wenn ich so zurück gucke, finde ich das schon bemerkenswert.
Also ich habe eigentlich angefangen, weil ich Geigenbau gemacht habe.
Geigenbau?
Ja.
Und dann stellt man relativ schnell fest, wenn man Geigen bauen will oder andere
Instrumente, da ist die Konkurrenz schon ziemlich hoch in der ganzen Welt.
Und da was vernünftiges zu bauen, war schwierig. Und dann habe ich gedacht,
was bräuchte man noch zusätzlich? Also nicht nur die Liebe zum Holz und zum
Instrument und zur Musik.
Und da war die Physik. Und da habe ich gedacht, gut, wenn du Physik kennst,
kannst du vielleicht noch besser messen, wie so ein Instrument funktioniert,
wie Schall funktioniert.
Studiere nochmal Physik, dann wirst du besser.
So mit den Frequenzüberlagerungen und Differenzen und so.
Also das war so meine Hoffnung. Und dann ist es aber so, es gibt hier am CERN
ein Sommerstudentenprogramm und durch das Studium an der Uni Bonn bin ich dann
einfach durch Zufall hier in das Sommerstudentenprogramm am CERN reingekommen.
Das war 1989, also schon relativ lang her.
Und dann plötzlich kam ich in eine Welt, die völlig anders war als das,
was ich kannte. Es war hier ein internationales Umfeld.
89 war auch noch die Zeit, da gab es noch die Mauer. Und trotzdem war hier schon
mein Supervisor aus der Sowjetunion noch.
Das war André Linde übrigens, ein ganz bekannter Kosmologe. Der hat mich da hier betreut.
Und zum ersten Mal, ich komme aus Westdeutschland, Da war das plötzlich so dieses
grenzenlose, diese Wissenschaft, die Offenheit und es war toll das zu spüren
und die ganzen anderen Studenten.
Und dann war es auch noch das Jahr, wo in China das Massaker Tiananmen Square
Studentenrevolte und CERN diente auch so als Auffanglager für Studenten und
Professoren aus China, die fliehen mussten.
Plötzlich war das hier voll mit Chinesen.
Wir hatten da auch so in Baracken geschlafen hier, so drei Bettzimmer,
so wie so eine alte Jugendherberge und dann waren wir so viele Leute hier plötzlich,
dass wir Schichten schlafen mussten.
Da wurde ich morgens von irgendjemandem geweckt, dann kam ich abends wieder
ans Bett, da lag da wahrscheinlich ein anderer und diese Atmosphäre.
Hier machen wir Wissenschaft, hier gehen wir vor allem Träumen nach,
Die eigentlichen, das merkt man bei mir auch, das kennt man vielleicht,
wenn man abends mal auf einer Wiese liegt und in die Sterne guckt.
Das ist so ein irre Gefühl, wenn man einen tollen Himmel hat und dann diese
Unendlichkeit des Weltraums sehen kann.
Geht es eigentlich darum, hier kann man erforschen, woher kommt eigentlich das
Ganze und woraus sind wir gemacht und vor allem wo geht es vielleicht auch noch hin.
Wie entwickelt sich unser Weltall. Das war einfach faszinierend und von dem
Moment an habe ich gesagt, na gut, lassen wir das mal mit dem Geigenbauen weiter.
Jetzt ist mein Ziel hier, werde ich weiter.
Hast du mal eine gebaut?
Ja klar.
Klang die auch so halbwegs?
Die klangen nicht schlecht, also ich kam vor allem vom Cello,
also das war ein Cello, die hab ich dann gemacht, aber ich hab auch eine Gitarre
und so gebaut, aber das konnte man mit Kernforschung nicht mithalten.
Genau, das konnte man nicht mithalten, weil das war wirklich so diese fundamentale
philosophische Frage worum es hier ging war plötzlich spannend und das vor allem
mit anderen Menschen zu machen und das ist großartig.
Und dann habe ich mein Studium in Bonn weitergemacht und abgeschlossen und hatte
dann erstmal Diplom und Doktorarbeit am DESI, am Deutschen Elektronen-Synchrotron,
oben in Hamburg gemacht.
Da gab es den tollen Beschleuniger HERA, der hat Elektronen auf Proton geschossen
und da habe ich dann Erfahrung gesammelt im, nicht mehr Geigenbau, sondern Detektorbau.
Und darauf habe ich mich auch spezialisiert. Wie baue ich Detektoren,
um elementare Teilchen nachzuweisen und dann rauszufinden, wie funktioniert das Ganze.
Und dann bin ich 1997 hier zum ersten Mal zum CERN gekommen,
nach der Doktorarbeit als junger Fellow und plötzlich wieder diese Freiheit,
die man hatte, diese internationalen großen Kollaborationen, das war großartig.
Und dann wie es so ist, ergibt sich plötzlich, ja jetzt machen wir hier nochmal
einen weiteren Postdoc.
Da hatte ich dann so einen Limited Duration Contract bekommen.
Und dann hörte der auf, dann hatte ich kurz eine Professur in Erlangen,
an der Uni Erlangen für Astroteilchenphysik, um auch mal was anderes zu machen,
weil man kann ja am besten lernen, indem man was anderen erklärt,
da muss man ja selber viel lernen.
Und dann war ich aber kaum hier weg, dann hat dann Cern wieder gesagt,
ja wir bauen ja gerade die Detektoren für den LAC und es fehlt schon,
dass du da bist, deswegen hier komm, bieten wir dir eine Stelle da dran.
Und dann hab ich natürlich gesagt, ja gut, zurück hierher.
Und damals war noch der Beschleuniger LEP, das war jetzt der Vorgänger von dem
Large Hadron Collider, im selben Tunnel.
Hat der Elektronen beschleunigt, Elektronen und Positronen aufeinander geschossen.
Ich arbeitete damals bei einem Experiment, das nannte sich Opal.
Und gleichzeitig war man aber auch schon dabei, Ende der oder in den 90ern,
um die Entwicklung für die Detektoren des LHC zu machen.
Und da habe ich dann beides gemacht. Es ist immer toll, wenn man zwei Sachen
macht. Einmal die Physik mit dem existierenden Beschleuniger und dann gleichzeitig
aber auch die Entwicklung für den neuen Beschleuniger.
Und ja, dieses Feuer brennt eigentlich immer noch hier, muss ich sagen.
Nicht schlecht. Genau so. Das heißt jetzt bist du Team von Atlas,
aber du hast sozusagen, also du leitest nicht nur, du warst sozusagen auch an
der Planung, an dem Bau selber konkret beschäftigt und damit also auch an der
ganzen Konzeptionsphase, also wirklich von Anfang an.
Und das ist ja eigentlich das Interessante, weil jetzt haben wir ja schon CMS
angeschaut und es ist ja klar, dass Atlas und CMS im Prinzip ja die selbe Aufgabe haben.
Sie sollen halt irgendwie diese Teilchen, die Hadronen,
die dort beschleunigt werden, aufnehmen und in diesen Paketierungen,
in die sie hereingeschossen kommen, dann eben kollidieren lassen und sich das anschauen.
Aber eben auf eine andere Art und Weise als CMS.
Und dann würde mich schon mal interessieren, wie es eigentlich dann sich genau
auf diese beiden Konzepte ergeben hat, weil,
Also hätte es noch drei, vier andere Varianten gegeben, die überhaupt in Frage
gekommen wären oder war schon klar, wenn man zwei haben will,
dann macht man es entweder so oder so, weil was anderes fällt uns nicht ein.
Wie findet man da überhaupt den Ansatz und wie sortiert sich das dann überhaupt
genau in diese zwei Konzepte?
Ja das ist eigentlich eine spannende Frage. Ich persönlich glaube,
würde ganz stark behaupten, das ist limitiert durchs Geld.
Also Physiker und ihre Ideen und Visionen, da gibt es so viele,
dass man wahrscheinlich von den Detektoren noch hätte 10 weitere mindestens bauen können.
Das Problem ist nur, irgendwann muss man sie halt dann auch wirklich bauen und
braucht dafür Geld und dann müssen sich halt die Leute zusammen finden,
die sowas machen. Ich will da gleich noch mal drauf zurückkommen,
aber erst noch mal ganz kurz, was sind eigentlich die Detektoren?
Eigentlich sind das nur große Kameras, die um den Kollisionspunkt der Protonen,
der Hadronen, wie du das auch gesagt hast, aufgebaut sind.
Und eigentlich macht man Schnappschüsse.
Man macht Schnappschüsse von so einer Kollision, weil wenn da zwei Protonen kollidieren,
dann gilt wieder die alte einsteinische Formel, die kennt jeder,
E gleich mc², da wird dann Energie in Masse umgewandelt, in Materie in verschiedene
Teilchen und die fliegen dann von diesem Kollisionspunkt in alle Richtungen weg.
Diese Detektoren sind nichts anderes als große Kameras, die man da drum setzt
und dann macht man im Prinzip Bilder von solchen Kollisionen,
also da wir so 40 Millionen Kollisionen pro Sekunde haben, sind das also riesen
Kameras mit 40 Millionen Bilder pro Sekunde.
Und dann, was wir dann mit diesen Bildern eigentlich machen ist,
weil die Energie, mit der die Protonen da zusammenstoßen, entspricht der Energiedichte
des frühen Universums ungefähr 10 und minus 12 Sekunden nach dem Urknall.
Das heißt unsere Beschleuniger sind nichts anderes als riesen Zeitmaschinen
und ich habe die Möglichkeit mit meinen Detektoren, mit meiner Kamera,
Fotos zu machen vom frühen Universum. Total spannend.
Und dann kann ich lämlich sagen, was passiert denn da eigentlich?
Was ist denn zu dieser Zeit des frühen Universums wirklich passiert?
Und dann gehe ich meine 40 Millionen Bilder pro Sekunde durch und dann lerne
ich im Prinzip die Regeln des frühen Universums.
Also so als Beispiel, wenn du Fußball nicht kennst, fängst du an oder irgendeinen
anderen Sport, fängst du an Bilder zu gucken und mit den Bildern lernst du dann die Regeln.
Und genauso machen wir das mit den Teilchen. Wir lernen die Regeln des frühen
Universums durch diese Bilder kennen, die wir uns dann angucken.
Und jetzt sind natürlich diese Kollaborationen, also diese Experimente wie ATLAS
und CMS, da sagt halt jeder Physiker, ich kann die beste Kamera bauen.
Und zwar sind die dann natürlich auch noch spezialisiert.
Jede Kameralage kann ein bisschen was anderes als die andere und der eine Physiker
sagt, ich kann super Kameralagen bauen, die können die Spuren der Teilchen super
präzise vermessen, die vom Wechselwirkungspunkt wegfliegen.
Andere sagen, ich kann super Kameras bauen, die können dann auch noch sagen,
was für ein Elementarteilchen das war.
Andere können sagen, ich baue dann auch noch so Kamerateile,
die sagen dir die Energie von diesen Teilchen, die da durchgeflogen sind.
Und wenn man das dann alles kombiniert, dann kriegt man halt dieses riesengroße Experiment.
Ja wie es so ist, viele Physiker, tolle Ideen und eigentlich wenn man jeden
fragt, sagt er ich baue jetzt einen super Detektor und die kommen ja auch, das ist ja keine.
Hierarchische Bundeswehr oder so, wo irgendein General sagt so jetzt baut ihr das.
Also zum Beispiel beim LHC, es ist nicht nur bei Atlas oder CMS,
war es ganz klar, wir wollen das Higgs-Teilchen finden. Das war eines der großen Ziele.
Also muss man die Kamera so bauen, dass sie sensibel darauf ist,
dass sie Higgs-Teilchen, so wie wir sie vermuten, dass sie zerfallen,
wirklich auch präzise und mit hoher Effizienz vermessen kann.
Und zum Beispiel ein ganz klares Foto oder Signatur nennen wir das von einem
zerfallenden Higgs-Teilchen, wenn es das gibt, sind zum Beispiel Elektronen,
zwei Elektronen oder zwei Myonen.
Also baut man dann die Kamera so, dass sie das super gut auflösen kann und dass
man dann aus diesen zwei Elektronenspuren, die man vermessen kann,
dann genau berechnen kann, was war die Masse des Teilchens, aus dem die beiden herausgekommen sind.
Und das gibt sozusagen die Anforderungen an die Kamera und dann sagt jeder,
ich habe da eine Idee, wie ich es mache. Und dann gehen sie los,
rennen sie los und bauen dann so eine Art Prototypen.
Und dann werden die dann getestet und mal ausprobiert und dann wird auch gezeigt,
ja, das stimmt auch mit den Summulationen überein. Also es funktioniert genauso
gut mit einer Auflösung, wie wir uns das erhofft haben.
Und dann wird das auch noch in Tests bewiesen und dann etablieren sich langsam
wirklich Technologien, welche man nehmen könnte und welche nicht.
Dann gibt es dann Unterschiede. Die eine hat dann wieder so viel Material,
dass die die Teilchen beeinflusst.
Andere sind dann leichter, haben dann auch wieder Vorteile. Und irgendwo findet
sich, ruckelt sich dann die ganze Gemeinschaft so zurecht, dass sie am Ende
dann im Prinzip einen wissenschaftlichen Shootout machen.
Und sagen, hier haben wir so ein Konzept, hier ist ein anderes Konzept,
welches von den beiden nehmen wir jetzt für unsere Kamera?
Und dann kommen so die Ideen. Und das andere sind natürlich was für Geldartner zur Verfügung.
Aber es gab auch so Vorgänger-Detektor-Technik, die in gewisser Hinsicht auch
so ein Leitmotiv dargestellt haben?
Klar, weil alle kommen ja mit ihrer Erfahrung. Es ist ja nicht so,
dass da irgendwelche Laien zusammenkommen, Sondern es sind meist Leute,
die zum Beispiel schon eine Spurkammer, also ein Kamerateil aufbauen,
die die Spuren der Teilchen ausliest.
Das macht man ja schon seit den 70ern und noch älter, dass man solche Teilchenkameras baut.
Und diese Erfahrung, da wollen sie dann immer sagen, jetzt kitzeln wir noch
ein bisschen mehr raus, machen hier noch ein bisschen mehr Technologie und nehmen
hier zum Beispiel neue leichte Materialien.
Also ich ganz konkret habe bei einem Kamerateil des Atlas mitgearbeitet,
war da auch lange Projektleiter.
Der nannte sich der Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor und das ist eigentlich eine Spurkammer,
funktioniert noch so ein bisschen wie so ein altes Geiger-Müller-Zellrohr, man hat so ein Röhrchen,
innen drin ist ein dünner Draht gespannt, in dem Röhrchen ist ein Gas und zwischen
der Röhrchenwand und dem Draht ist ein elektrisches Feld und wenn da jetzt so
ein Teilchen durchfliegt, Dann ionisiert es das Gas und die Elektronen driften
hin zum Draht und machen da ein Signal.
Und wenn du dann über 100.000 von solchen Röhrchen hast, dann siehst du wirklich
wie so Perlen auf einer Schnur, wo das Teilchen lang geflogen ist.
Dann spricht das eine Röhrchen an, dann das andere. Und wenn man das dann visualisiert,
sieht man richtig, ja da ging eine Spur lang.
Und dieser Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor kann dann auch zusätzlich sagen,
was für ein Teilchen das war. War das ein Elektron oder ein Pion,
was da durchgeflogen ist? Und den ersten habe ich damals bei Zeuss bei Hera
gebaut. Das habe ich da am Liese gelernt.
Und dann hatte man die Ideen dann auch, wie kann man das hier besser machen.
Jetzt hatte man neue Materialien, Verbundstoffe, so Carbon, Fibers und so was, alles hat Spaß gemacht.
Und damit hat man das dann optimiert. Und andere Kollegen zum Beispiel,
die waren es gewohnt große Detektorteile zu bauen, die haben die Energie von Teilchen gemessen.
Kalorimeter nennen sich die. Und da hat man dann auch neue Ideen gehabt,
wie kann man die noch größer und noch präziser machen.
Und da, wie gesagt, gab es dann immer solche Kollaborationen,
die erst mal Prototypen gemacht haben und diese Prototypen wurden dann zum Beispiel
auch in Teststrahlen hier am CERN getestet und dann hat man gesehen,
was ist die Performance?
Was ist der Preis? Und dann konnte man sich auch was einigen.
Es gab ja glaube ich auch andere Planungen vorher, so Eagle oder Escort,
das waren so ähnliche Detektorkonzepte oder die sind auch gebaut worden?
Ne, die wurden, also das sind solche Konzepte, ich sagte ja am Anfang tun sich
dann die Freunde zusammen und sagen jetzt bauen wir mal einen und dem geben
wir mal einen Namen. Also für Physiker ist es immer wichtig,
dass ein Projekt einen geilen Namen hat.
Da wird auch alles getan, dass es am Ende eine Abkürzung ist,
die noch cool klingt, auch wenn es mit dem Begriff nichts mehr zu tun hat.
Klar. Da ist Atlas auch ein gutes Beispiel für, finde ich.
Furchtbar, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Ateroidal Apparatus for LHC Physics,
also es ist ein echtes Konstrukt, klar. Da sind die CMS Kollegen ein bisschen
kreativer gewesen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das kreativer hält.
Ja gut, stimmt. Am Ende ist es einfach nur ein Drei Buchstaben Abkürzung.
Trotzdem, dann nennt man natürlich auch seine Vorläufer oder seine Ideenprojekte,
denen gibt man natürlich auch Namen. Muss sein.
Und dann versucht man halt diese Dinger, die man sich vorgenommen hat,
ob Eagle oder Ascot heißt, Prototypen zu bauen, das dann zu testen und wie gesagt,
wenn man dann gesagt hat, der von Eagle funktioniert aber jetzt besser als der
von Ascot, Dann sagt man, okay, diese Kamerakomponente nehmen wir jetzt von dem.
Diese Kamerakomponente von dem anderen und so bauen sich dann die Nachfolger,
also Atlas, dann zusammen aus mehreren Konzeptstudien.
Das Wichtige und das ist das, was die Teilchenphysiker eigentlich super können.
Eigentlich ist es ja so, wenn man ein Konzept hat und das wird nicht genommen,
da ist ja jeder erst mal stinkbeleidigt und das ist furchtbar.
Vor allem muss man sich auch vorstellen, die haben ja auch Geld,
die Leute. Und eigentlich will man ja das Geld dann haben, um das in seine Kamerakomponente,
Detektorkomponente zu packen.
Und man muss dafür immer sorgen, in der Soziologie der Kollaboration,
dass man keine Verlierer schafft.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz wichtig. Deswegen nimmt man den wissenschaftlichen,
versucht man das über einen ganz wissenschaftlichen Ansatz, welches funktioniert
besser und welches ist vielleicht günstiger.
Also Preis-Nutzen-Verhältnis und dann einigt man sich. Und dann versucht man
auch den anderen, den Konkurrenten aber dann auch wieder an Bord zu holen,
sodass man das dann zusammen macht.
Und nur so erreicht man es dann, dass plötzlich 3000 Leute, wie in dem Fall
der Atlas-Kollaboration, zusammenhalten und hinter einem einzigen Konzept stehen,
was sie vorher von ihren verschiedenen Studien übernommen haben. Das ist faszinierend.
Es ist ja in der Regel sehr international aber auch sehr europäisch geprägt.
Aber bei Atlas gab es auch so eine US Komponente.
Sogar bei CMS mehr natürlich. Aber das hat auch bei uns Tradition.
Also natürlich das CERN ist ein europäisches Labor. Das heißt es sind nur europäische
Länder die im Prinzip im Rat, im Council daher kommt der Name,
Konseil Europäens pour la Recherche Nucléaire, also im Ratssitzen.
Diese Länder, die das CERN betreiben und da auch Mitgliedsbeitrag bezahlen,
die entscheiden natürlich über das wissenschaftliche Programm.
Aber dennoch ist es so, dass es auch viele Leute und Wissenschaftler in anderen
Ländern gibt, Japan, USA, weiß Gott, you name it, die wollen gerne da auch mitmachen.
Und unsere Gemeinschaft, die Gemeinschaft der Forschenden, ist derartig immer
schon international, dass es natürlich gar keine Frage ist. klar macht ihr mit.
Ihr bezahlt dann halt auch einen Teil des Experiments.
Ihr übernehmt auch Pflichten. Das ist auch ganz wichtig. Das muss ja alles betrieben
werden. Aber dann macht ihr mit.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass die jetzt über das CERN bestimmen können.
Das ist okay, aber das ist den Wissenschaftlern eigentlich auch erstmal egal.
So, was wurde denn dann beschlossen, was man bauen soll? Also wir hatten ja
mit dem CMS schon gesprochen und das wesentliche Merkmal des CMS steckt ja auch im Namen.
Es steht für Solenoid, also letzten Endes eine große Spule,
eine Riesenspule, die sozusagen dieses Magnetfeld erzeugt,
was ja immer erforderlich ist bei dieser ganzen Geschichte, weil man will ja
diese hochenergetischen Teilchen, die in alle Richtungen platzen,
irgendwie im Zaum halten und dabei eben vermessen.
Beim Atlas steckt es auch im Namen, das ist das T-Toroidel, besser bekannt als Donut.
Also sozusagen so ein Ringkernmagneten.
Ja also erstmal haben sie beide natürlich ein Solonoin, aber das ist schon richtig.
CMS hat einen riesengroßen Trump, während Atlas hat einen anderen Ansatz von
dem ganzen Magnetsystem her.
Und zwar hat man einmal bei Atlas dann gesagt, gut, oder das ist eigentlich
auch bei CMS genau dasselbe erstmal, hinter den Kollisionspunkt.
Die erste Kameralage, die man braucht.
Das sind Spurdetektoren, die dann nämlich genau vermessen können,
wie die Spuren von den kollidierenden oder die Teilchen von den kollidierenden
Protonen weggeflogen sind.
Und da sind die Konzepte mit sogenannten Siliziumdetektoren,
Siliziumpixeldetektoren und Siliziumstreifendetektoren sehr ähnlich von Atlas und CMS.
Also da, ein Experte bei Atlas, der kennt auch das CMS-System und umgekehrt.
Das CMS-System ist was die Siliziumdetektoren angeht größer,
weil damals hatte man noch nicht so viel Erfahrung mit diesen Siliziumdetektoren
und die waren halt mutig und haben gesagt, wir bauen ein ganz großes System.
Bei Atlas waren wir dann ein bisschen konservativer und haben vor allem aber
auch gesagt, es ist auch wichtig, schon in dem Spursystem Teilchen identifizieren zu können.
Dass man sagen kann, das ist ein Proton, das ist ein Elektron,
das ist ein Pion oder das ist ein Myon oder weiß Gott was.
Und deswegen hat der Atlas Silizium Detektor Pixel und Streifen noch diesen
Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor TRT,
das ist im Prinzip diese Röhrchen, die ich eben beschrieben hatte,
drumherum und da kann man dann auch noch Spuren nochmals zusätzlich vermessen
aber vor allem auch sagen, was für ein Teilchen das war.
Das war eine ganz wichtige Sache, die wir uns damals überlegt hatten,
weil auf der Suche nach dem Higgs war es wichtig, Zerfälle des Higgs-Teilchens in Elektronen.
Genau aufzuzeichnen und genau zu vermessen, weil da wusste man,
da kann man ganz genau die Masse des Higgs-Teilchens damit bestimmen.
Und dadurch, dass diese Event-Bilder,
also diese Fotos, die man macht, die sind ja so voll von allen möglichen Teilchen
und wenn man da dann diese Elektronen ganz genau sehen und vermessen kann,
dann hilft das schon auf der Suche nach dem Higgs und es hilft auch später das
sogenannte Kalorimeter, das dann um die Spurdetektoren gebaut ist,
auch noch zu kalibrieren.
Das war ganz wichtig. Und dann gehen die Unterschiede auch weiter,
nämlich bei Atlas kommt dann erstmal eine Spule, ein Supraleitender Magnet,
tatsächlich um diese Spurdetektoren.
Und der Magnet hat ja eigentlich nicht die Aufgabe, die Teilchen zusammenzuhalten,
sondern das ist eigentlich so, geladene Teilchen in einem Magnetfeld fliegen so eine gekrümmte Bahn.
Und aufgrund der Krümmung kann man dann einmal sagen, sind die positiv oder
negativ geladen, weil die einen krümmen sich in die eine Richtung und die anderen
in die andere. Und man kann vor allem sagen, wie viel Energie haben die oder
wie schnell sind die Teilchen.
Wir nennen das Energie, aber im Prinzip wie schnell sind diese Teilchen.
Ein ganz schnelles Teilchen wird in diesem Magnetfeld ganz wenig nur gekrümmt.
Ein total langsames Teilchen ziemlich stark, das macht sogar schon fast so Kringelchen.
Und damit kann man dann auch, wenn man die Energie dieser Teilchen präzise vermisst,
kann man genauer auch berechnen, woher aus welchen Teilchen Zerfall kommen,
diese Spuren, die wir jetzt gerade gemessen haben.
Und dann hat der Atlas schon einen kleineren Magneten um diese Spurkammern und
dann kommen bei Atlas noch Kalorimeter, die vermessen dann die Energien der Teilchen ganz genau.
Und dann kommt noch eine entscheidende Detektorkomponente, sowohl bei CMS als
auch bei Atlas. Das sind die sogenannten Möhrenkammern.
Myonen kennt man klar, kosmische Strahlung, sind ja immer da.
Fliegen sind die schweren Brüder der Elektronen. Und wann immer so in so einem
Foto so ein schwerer Bruder eines Elektrons auftaucht, kann man schon sagen,
oh, das ist wahrscheinlich ein interessantes Foto.
Und wir wissen auch, Higgs zerfällt auch gerne in zwei Myonen.
Das heißt, wenn ich diese Sache auch noch ganz präzise messen kann,
dann habe ich vielleicht noch höhere Statistik, um die Masse des Higgs-Teilchens zu finden.
Und deswegen hat ATLAS noch in diesen Myondetektoren, die ganz außen sind,
ein zusätzliches Magnetsystem eingebaut und das sind diese acht Toroidspulen,
die eigentlich dann nochmal genau in dem Myondetektor ein gutes präzises magnetisches
Feld erzeugen, dass man diese Spuren der Myonen in den Myonenkammern auch noch
sehr präzise vermessen kann.
Und das ist ein großer Unterschied zwischen ATLAS und CMS.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt im Prinzip für das Hauptmagnetfeld, was erstmal für
die Primärkrümmung sorgt, da sind sie sich eher ähnlich.
Aber es kommt sozusagen in dieser allerletzten Stufe, in dieser Myonschicht
sozusagen, kommt nochmal was so um sozusagen die, was kann man dann,
dann kann man die Energie noch genauer messen oder?
Genau, dann hat man da noch eine höhere Präzision um die Energie oder Geschwindigkeit zu verändern.
Präzision, das ist eigentlich das worum es geht. Gerade wenn man am Ende so
viele Milliarden Kollisionen beobachtet und da eine statistische Aussage draus machen will,
dann wäre ja quasi eine Ungenauigkeit die einmal auftritt, tritt ja dann auch
milliardenfach auf und dann multipliziert sich das dann entsprechend.
Das heißt der Aufbau der beiden Detektoren ist so unterschiedlich eigentlich
nicht, wo zieht man denn dann quasi die Grenze, dass man sagt,
Es ist aber jetzt unterschiedlich genug, sodass wir eben auch wirklich das eine
zur Überprüfung des anderen heranziehen können,
weil das Ziel der ganzen Idee ist ja nicht nur,
dass man zwei hat, weil die dann, was weiß ich, wenn der eine einen Defekt hat,
dann ist der andere immer noch heile, Sondern es geht ja auch darum,
konzeptionell anders zu arbeiten, damit man eben nicht schon in seiner Messmethode
selber so ein Bias mit drin hat
und am Ende irgendetwas meint festzustellen, was tatsächlich nur in dieser technischen
Konstellation auftritt, aber ansonsten halt nie auftreten würde.
Das ist ja sozusagen der Hintergedanke, warum
man überhaupt zwei solche General-Purpose-Detektoren ja auch hinbaut.
Aber wenn jetzt sozusagen der große Magnet ist identisch und die Spurdetekstitution
ist ähnlich, dann die nächste Phase war ein bisschen anders.
Woran kann man das auch quantifizieren, dass das anders genug ist?
In so einer wissenschaftlichen Bewertung wird das ja wohl auch genau gemacht
worden sein. Es wird ja sicherlich die Pläne auf dem Tisch gewesen sein und
jemand wird gesagt haben müssen, okay das ist jetzt auch anders genug.
Ne, das an sich, es gab so kein Komitee, von äußeren Experten oder von nicht
internen Experten, die dann gesagt haben, sind die Unterschiede groß genug.
Also ganz wichtig und das ist ja schon mal der allergrößte Unterschied ist,
es wurde von verschiedenen Menschen gebaut.
Es wurden die kleinen Details von verschiedenen Physikern und Ingenieuren designt
und vor allem auch die Software zur Auswertung der Bilder wird unabhängig von
anderen Leuten geschrieben.
Ich persönlich würde sagen, es geht noch nicht mal um den großen analytischen
Unterschied einer Detektorkamera,
aber wir wollen natürlich auch immer herausfordernde Technologien bauen,
was jetzt nicht so schon 20 Jahre alt ist, sondern was gerade mal state of the art ist.
Und da weiß man manchmal noch nicht, funktioniert das, wird das eigentlich auch
wirklich funktionieren.
Das sagte ich ja. Also CMS war sehr, sehr, ich finde das tapfer und richtig,
dass die da gesagt haben, wir bauen halt nur Silizium in die.
In die inneren Spurkammern. Und da war Atlas halt konservativer,
weil man gesagt hat, okay vielleicht funktioniert das ja ganz gar nicht und
wir sind vielleicht zu optimistisch.
Dann hat man bei Atlas halt noch zusätzlich diesen Gasdetektor Old Fashioned
Technology gehabt. Also es ist auch eine Art Risikominimierung, die man dadurch macht.
Und bei CMS zum Beispiel, die Kalorimeter sind so Kristallkalorimeter,
die mit extrem hoher Präzision auch die Energie vermessen, aber da war man auch
nicht ganz sicher, halten die überhaupt in den Strahlenschäden das ganze aus.
Also es ist nicht unbedingt, dass jemand gesagt hat, hier das ist so anders,
das reicht jetzt, das ist anders genug, sondern es ist wirklich auch eine Risikoabwägung,
dass man manchmal sagt, okay das ist neu, das ist etwas konservativer.
Und dann macht natürlich ein riesen Unterschied die Software,
die die Sachen auswählt, beziehungsweise auch die Trigger, die überhaupt entscheiden,
welche von den Bildern will man wegschreiben. Das haben wir ja noch gar nicht
gesagt, aber 40 Millionen Bilder pro Sekunde kann man gar nicht speichern.
Wir können das, das war am Anfang so, dass man vielleicht so auf ein paar hundert
Bilder gekommen ist, jetzt bauen wir gerade, rüsten wir das auf,
dass wir auf tausend Bilder pro Sekunde sind, die wir überhaupt aufzeichnen können.
Und das ist zum Beispiel auch, da es von anderen Leuten gemacht wird,
aber auch teilweise auch andere Technologie in den Computer,
Elektronik genommen wird, auch so unterschiedlich,
dass wirklich von der Systematik her der eine Detektor ganz anders ist und unabhängig
von dem anderen und insofern ist es richtig wie du das gesagt hast,
wenn der eine was misst und der andere nicht, dann ist da echt was faul.
Bei einem oder dem anderen.
So auch wenn wir das bei CMS im Prinzip schon mal durchgespielt haben,
ist es glaube ich trotzdem wert nochmal wirklich diese Funktionsweise jetzt
von innen nach außen auch mal so ein bisschen im zeitlichen Ablauf nachzuvollziehen,
weil daran kann man sicherlich auch nochmal feststellen, wo im Detail die Unterschiede
dann durch unterschiedliche Messmethoden herauskommen.
Also wie eben bei dem anderen Detektor, bei allen Detektoren auch,
die Teilchen kommen so gebündelt in so Paketen,
25 Nanosekunden Abstand vom LHC,
werden sie da sozusagen hinein gepulst und kreuzen sich dann sozusagen mit den
entgegenfliegenden Protonenhäufchen an einem entsprechenden Punkt und dort gibt
es dann eben mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit Kollisionen.
Und sogar mehr als eine.
Mehr als eine, aber vielleicht auch nicht so viele wie man jetzt als Laie erstmal
denken möchte, wenn man sich anschaut, dass da jetzt irgendwie 100 Milliarden
Teilchen aufeinander prasseln.
Dafür ist relativ wenig los. Gibt ja auch ein schönes Äquivalent dazu so in
der Kosmologie, wenn man sich dann halt mal so Theorien anschaut mit Galaxien verschmelzen.
Ja das ist ja auch so ein Ereignis, so
hier Andromeda Galaxie wird uns ja irgendwann mal hier auf Kollisionskurs mit der Milchstraße gehen,
werden wir jetzt,
nicht mehr so richtig miterleben, aber wird vermutlich stattfinden.
Da ist er eigentlich noch leer. Aber deswegen, dann hat man Glück und es stoßen
ein paar zusammen und bleiben wir jetzt aber dann von einer von denen,
die picken wir mal raus, das heißt diese Protonen prallen aufeinander,
es entsteht Energie und jetzt gemäß E gleich mc² wandelt sich diese Energie
jetzt wieder in Teilchen um. Wie in welche Teilchen?
Warum entsteht Energie?
Also entsteht die Energie oder ist die nicht in den Teilchen schon drin?
Ok, da hast du recht. Also sie entsteht nicht, sondern die Bewegungsenergie,
die Teilchen haben ja fast Lichtgeschwindigkeit, die ist wie zwei Autos,
wenn die zusammenprallen, dann haben die natürlich schon ihre Energie vom Fahren,
aber dann in diesem kleinen Punkt Die Energie wird umgewandelt.
Umgewandelt und ist dann einfach als Energie da und kann dann neue Teilchen erzeugen.
Und diese fliegen dann halt, also leben meist ganz kurz nur,
weil es sind ja nur wenige elementare Teilchen wirklich stabil.
Also das Elektron kennen wir, ist stabil, aber selbst das Myon,
was wir schon aus der Kosmologie kennen, die kosmische Strahlung,
lebt ja, hat ja auch nur eine gewisse Lebensdauer.
Aber die meisten Teilchen zerfallen dann recht wieder und zerfallen in diese
stabilen Teilchen wie Elektron oder quasi stabile Teilchen wie Myon und Pion
und die fliegen dann halt durch unsere Schichten der Kamera und die ersten Schichten
oder die ersten Schichten sind die bei Atlas,
dass genau die Spur fest gelegt wird, dass man zum Beispiel sagen kann...
Die Kollision war hier, aber jetzt ein bisschen weiter davon weg.
Da entstehen plötzlich noch weitere Teilchen oder da ist ein anderer Vertex, nennen wir das.
Das ist immer so ein Hinweis, dass da zum Beispiel noch Teilchen wieder zerfallen
sind, die kurz entstanden sind. Zum Beispiel Teilchen mit B-Quarks drin.
Wir sind aber wichtig zu identifizieren, weil die helfen uns zum Beispiel auch
das Higgs zu finden. Immer wenn schwere Teilchen involviert sind,
war es gut, dass man gucken konnte, diese Fotos guckt ihr an,
da ist vielleicht dann das Higgs.
Und diese Spuren werden dann ganz genau aufgezeichnet und vor allem auch,
weil sie ja in dem Magnetfeld drin sind, sehr präzise vermessen,
was für Impulse sie haben.
Aber wodurch werden sie denn konkret detektiert an dieser Stelle?
Also wie funktioniert Silizium? Das ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als jede Handykamera.
Also man hat eine Halbleiterschicht.
Diese Halbleiterschicht, die hat dann auch am unteren Ende Auslesepads,
die dann auf elektronische Bausteine geführt werden, wie zum Beispiel Verstärker.
Aber dann ist es genauso wie eben schon beschrieben.
Ein Teilchen fliegt durch ein Material durch, wo eine Spannung angelegt ist.
Zwischen oben und unten dieser Sensoren ist eine Spannung angelegt und wenn da ein Teilchen,
ein geladenes Teilchen durchfliegt, dann erzeugt es da in dem Silizium solche
Löcher oder erzeugt freie Elektronen,
die dann zu einem bestimmten Punkt gesammelt werden und da dann als elektrisches
Signal abgegriffen werden. Und jetzt, wenn diese Pixel...
Durch die die fliegen können, klein genug sind, 25 Mikrometer,
dann hat man damit ja schon eine unwahrscheinlich gute Ortsauflösung.
Allein schon deswegen, grob 25 Mikrometer mal 25 Mikrometer,
da ist es durchgeflogen, also weiß ich schon ziemlich genau, wo die Spur ist.
Wenn ich mehrere davon habe, kann ich dann auch noch diese Spuren kombinieren
und da es ja gerade fliegen muss, kann man das sehr präzise machen,
dann geht das nochmal, verbessert sich die Auflösung noch um Faktoren.
Und damit ist man dann schon ziemlich genau und präzise in der Spurauflösung.
Wir haben da verschiedene Lagen, also je näher man an dem Kollisionen dran ist,
dann hilft das der Spurrekonstruktion.
Zum Beispiel bei Atlas ist glaube ich die innere Lage noch näher dran als bei CMS, hilft uns.
Dann gibt es vier Lagen, die nach außen gehen von diesen Pixeln.
Und danach gibt es dann diese Siliciumstreifen, funktionieren ganz genauso,
nicht 25 Mikrometer auf 50 Mikrometer, sondern sind halt lange Streifen,
mehrere Zentimeter, aber auch relativ dünn.
Trotzdem, wenn man das dann im Algorithmus kombiniert, mit den Spuren kann man
das sehr genau verändern.
Warum wechselt man, also die inneren sind wie bei CMS solche Folien,
die sozusagen in so Pixel aufgeteilt sind.
Ja, wie so Handykamera-Tipps, also die Fotos, CCDs, genau.
Und inwiefern ändert sich das jetzt von der Struktur ins Streifen?
Also ist es dann immer noch eine Folie, die sich anders bestückt oder wo ist der Unterschied?
Also das sind ja solche Fässer, diese Kameras, wie wir sie aufgebaut haben.
Die Pixel sind quadratisch und da kann man ganz viele Pixel nebeneinander und
hintereinander nebeneinander machen.
Aber je weiter man nach außen geht, desto größer wird ja auch diese Oberfläche
des Fasses, die da drum ist. Das heißt dann ist es plötzlich eine Kostenfrage.
Weil natürlich wäre es genial, wenn wir da auch noch Pixel hätten,
aber dann wird es zu teuer, weil jeder Pixel hat ja einen eigenen Auslese-Elektronikkanal
und eigentlich berechnet sich dann auch so ein Kostenpunkt.
Also das heißt man lässt quasi eine Dimension weg und hat einfach nur noch die
Linie sozusagen wo es durch geht.
Richtig, genau und dadurch, dass man aber vorher Pixel hat, kriegt man grob
ja auch schon die Information, wo es lang geflogen ist, dann braucht man das nicht mehr, ganz genau.
Und bei CMS sind diese Streifendetektoren, gehen dann noch zu höherem Radius,
weg vom Kollisionspunkt.
Bei Atlas hat man dann halt diese Röhrchendetektoren, Gasröhrchen,
kleine 4 mm dicken Röhrchen mit dem Draht da drin und wenn da das Teilchen durchfliegt,
dann ionisiert es das Gas und macht da auf dem Draht dann ein elektrisches Signal
und das sind dann auch mindestens 32 von diesen Röhrchen durch diese und Teilchen
dann von innen nach außen durchfliegt.
Und die geben dann auch noch genaue Informationen, wo das langgeflogen ist,
aber vor allem auch Informationen, ob das zum Beispiel ein Elektron gewesen ist oder ein Pion.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar, wie dieses Röhrchen sozusagen, also was misst es jetzt genau?
Also da ist der Draht, das Teilchen fliegt durch, das Gas ionisiert,
also erzeugt dann, erzeugen ist mal ein schwieriges Wort, also kommen dann Elektroden,
werden da welche frei oder was?
Klar die werden aus dem Atom, aus dem Gasatom richtig rausgehauen.
Okay und die fliegen dann sozusagen zu diesem Draht und erzeugen in dem Moment
einen Impuls für das ganze Röhrchen oder hat man da wirklich einen Zeitverlauf den man da misst?
Ja, richtig. Man hat nämlich ein bisschen einen Zeitverlauf.
Also das einzelne Röhrchen.
Da fliegt das Teilchen durch den Querschnitt durch, trifft natürlich nicht immer
die Mitte, sondern so ein bisschen am Rand zwischen der Röhrchenwand und dem Draht.
Also die fliegt eher quer durch als längs? Ja genau, richtig.
Also die Röhrchen sind sozusagen entlang des ganzen Fasses. Also wenn man sich
diese Kamera als Fass vorstellt, dann sind die im Prinzip entlang der Fasswände.
Parallel zum Teilchenbeschleuniger sozusagen.
Also sie gehen von der Seite durch die Rohre durch, also die treffen irgendwo auf diesem Rohr auf.
Ja oder fliegen durch das Rohr durch, ionisieren und dann ist ja zwischen der
äußeren Hülle des Röhrchens und dem Draht ist ein elektrisches Feld.
Und die Elektronen, die dann rausgekickt wurden aus dem Gas,
die driften dann hin zu dem Draht, einfach aufgrund des elektrischen Feldes.
Und das elektrische Feld ist so stark, dass ein einzelnes Elektron dann noch
weitere Elektronen aus dem Gas rauskickt, weil es so ein bisschen in dem Feld beschleunigt wird.
Und dadurch hat man dann, sagen wir mal, pro ein Elektron, was vielleicht ionisiert
durch Ionisation des Teilchens entstanden ist, 10.000,
elektrosekundäre Elektronen, die durch diese Gasverstärkung,
also durch das elektrische Feld kommen und das erzeugt ein Signal,
was groß genug Größend gelesen werden kann.
Und das ist aber auch nur eine eindimensionale Information wie bei diesen Siliziumstreifen
oder kann man dann tatsächlich an Laufzeiten dann von diesem Draht auch noch
messen, wo das da durchgegangen ist?
Ja, also an Laufzeit kann man tatsächlich berechnen, dass man sie an beiden Seiten ausliest.
Wir haben aber festgestellt, braucht man gar nicht, weil durch die Information
der Siliziumdetektoren zuvor,
wo es vorher war, hat man das schon relativ gut zugeordnet bekommen.
Aber tatsächlich ist eine Zeitinformation schon wichtig, weil wir wissen ja
alle 25 Nanosekunden gibt es vielleicht ein neues Bild und eine neue Kollision.
Das heißt aber, wenn zum Beispiel so ein Draht ein Signal sieht,
dann kommt der ja nicht zum genauen Zeitpunkt der Kollision,
sondern ein bisschen nachher.
Und diese Zeit nachher berechnet sich aus der Flugzeit des Teilchens über diesen
Meter, selbst wenn es Lichtgeschwindigkeit hat, ist das doch,
reden wir doch schon darüber.
Das dauert auch ein bisschen.
Und durch die Driftgeschwindigkeit innerhalb des Röhrchens von der Wand hin zum Draht.
Und damit kann man dann auch noch ganz genau, wo genau in dem Röhrchen selber
das durchgeflogen ist, bestimmen.
Also Zeitmessung ist eine ganz wichtige Sache für uns und das wird auch für
die Zukunft immer wichtiger. Zeitmessung, also 4D-Informationen.
Wir machen demnächst halt nicht nur diese dreidimensionalen Bilder,
sondern dann auch noch die Zeitkomponente kommt auch noch dazu.
Naja, das sind die Spurdetektoren.
Entschuldigung, wie viel Strecke haben wir jetzt zurückgelegt,
bis wir am Ende dieser Röhrchen angekommen sind?
Genau, das ist ungefähr ein Meter. Also muss man sich vorstellen,
zwei Meter im Durchmesser hat diese Kameradicke des inneren Detektors für die Spuren.
Daraufhin kommt dann die Spule. Das ist dieser Magnet, den du kurz angesprochen hast.
Supraleitender Magnet und der
ist bei Atlas auch sehr dünn, hat aber nicht so die Stärke wie bei CMS.
Der krümmt die Teilchenbahn. Und hinter dem Magneten kommt dann das Kalorimeter.
Und hier bei Atlas haben wir was besonderes. Es ist nämlich ein Flüssig-Argon-Kalorimeter.
Also Kalorimeter ist sozusagen der Energiemesser und auch so ein bisschen die
potenzielle Endstation für die allermeisten Teilchen.
Genau, richtig. Also Kalorimeter misst die Energie der einzelnen Teilchen.
Deswegen bestehen solche Kalorimeter meist oder eigentlich immer aus schweren
Materialien, wie zum Beispiel irgendwelche Bleiplatten oder Stahlplatten, Kupferplatten.
Da fliegen dann die Teilchen rein und machen Schauern auf, geben ihre Energie
ab, indem sie wieder weitere elektromagnetische Schauer oder Teilchen erzeugen.
Die muss man dann jetzt aber auch noch nachweisen und da hat man das dann so,
dass man so eine Absorberschicht immer hat und dazwischen dann eine Schicht
mit flüssigem Argon und da ist jetzt wieder genau derselbe Trick fast wie bei
diesen Röhrchen, die ich vorher beschrieben habe.
Dieses flüssig Argon wird auch wieder ionisiert,
wenn da diese Teilchenschauer drin sind und wenn man dann auf der anderen Seite
zwischen der Absorberschicht Liquid Argon und dann eine Schicht Elektronik hinbaut,
dann messen die wieder die entstandenen Schauerteilchen und können dann wieder
genau sagen, hier haben wir einen Stromimpuls gesehen, der so und so groß ist.
Und dafür sind immer diese Messungen oder wir nennen das Teststrahlen vorher
unglaublich wichtig, dass man kalibriert.
Wenn wir einen elektrischen Impuls sehen, der so und so groß ist,
dann entspricht das einem Teilchen mit der und der Energie.
Und diese Kalorimeter sind relativ dick, also das sind mehrere 10 Zentimeter,
so dass man viele Teilchen vermessen kann und genau aufzeichnen kann.
Und vor allem diese elektromagnetischen Kalorimeter, das sind die,
die der innere Teil eines großen Kalorimeters bildet, die messen präzise die
Energie der Elektronen.
Diese Kalorimeter sind auch meist so dick, dass jedes Elektron bis dahin gut
absorbiert ist, wenn es diese paar 10 Zentimeter durchquert hat.
Das hat CMS auch. CMS hat nicht einen Liquid-Argon-Kalorimeter,
sondern einen Kristall-Kalorimeter.
Da wird dann der Lichtimpuls gemessen, wenn da so ein Teilchen aufschaut.
Genau, mit diesem Blei-Wolframat-Kristall.
Wir messen halt Elektronen, aber das funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Wir haben aber bei uns auch tatsächlich den Vorteil bei Atlas dadurch,
dass diese Kalorimeter so aufgebaut sind,
dass sie auch wieder genau, und du hast das genau richtig schön beschrieben,
parallel zum Strahlverlauf gehen und dann auch noch so eine leichte Akkordeonform
haben, kann man genau sagen auch aus welcher Richtung das Elektronen gekommen
ist. Also das funktioniert relativ gut.
Und das hat uns auch geholfen bei der Higgs-Entdeckung.
Ja und dann um dieses elektromagnetische Kalorimeter kommt dann immer noch ein
atronisches Kalorimeter und das ist viel Material und da hofft man dann,
dass dann auch die ganzen restlichen Teilchen aufschauern.
Und ganz wichtig war, die inneren Spurlagen, die vermessen ja nur Teilchen,
die geladen sind. Da dachte ich, ja das geht nur über Ionisation.
Aber die Kalorimeter vermessen auch Teilchen, die elektrisch neutral sind.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel Neutronen, kennt man ja, oder Pion, ungeladene Pion,
das P0, weil die auch in dem Material aufschauern.
Das heißt, Kalorimeter vermessen nicht nur die geladenen Teilchen,
sondern, und das ist für die Gesamtenergiebilanz wichtig, alle Teilchen, auch die ungeladenen.
Klar, kein Teilchen vermisst Neutrinos, aber das ist okay.
Dafür braucht man Kilometer Eiswürfel in der Antarktis.
Ja, aber wir schaffen es tatsächlich auch Neutrinos in dem Sinne nachzuweisen,
dass wir sie eben nicht messen. Da muss ich aber nachher drauf kommen,
weil das ist eine ganz wichtige Eigenschaft eines Detektors,
um zum Beispiel dunkle Materieteilchen finden zu können. Da kommen wir gleich drauf.
Und dann außen rum kommen noch die Muonkammern. Das ist auch wieder ganz wichtig.
Bei beiden CMS und Atlas ist nämlich die Teilchen, die durch das ganze Material
durchfliegen, das sind die schweren Brüder der Elektronen, die Muon, auch geladen.
Teilchen und die werden dann auch wieder von Von Detektoren,
meist sind das Gasdetektoren, funktioniert eigentlich immer so,
dass man zwei Platten hat.
Dazwischen ist ein sehr starkes elektrisches Feld und da ist auch wieder ein
Gas reingefüllt und wenn da ein Teilchen durchfliegt dann macht es da wieder
eine Ionisation und dann gibt es im Prinzip einen Funkendurchschlag von der
oberen Platte bis zur unteren.
Das ist ja eigentlich so wie so ein Ding was man in der Bäckerei hat um die
Fliegen tot zu machen, also die sind dann da außen herum aufgebaut und wann
immer da so ein Ding durchfliegt dann macht es einen Knall oder dann sieht man
einen Lichtblitz und dann kann man das aufzeichnen.
Okay, so ein Large Scale Fliegenfänger, um Teilchen zum Knallen zu bringen.
Aber das Wichtige ist halt wirklich, die Dinger sind so aufgebaut, also einmal das Fass,
habe ich natürlich nicht so gut beschrieben, aber es ist wirklich das Fass parallel
zu der Strahlrichtung drum herum und damit das Fass auch noch geschlossen ist,
damit keine Teilchen irgendwie so noch entkommen in Richtung des Strahlrohrs,
sind dann noch so zwei Fassdeckel drauf gebaut.
Und damit umschließt man den Wechselwirkungsfang fast komplett.
Und das ist auch wichtig, weil klar das Higgs war eine tolle Sache und dafür
haben wir auch die Detektoren gebaut. Aber meine persönliche Motivation ist
eigentlich eine ganz andere. Ich will dunkle Materie finden.
Das ist das wieso ich hier eigentlich arbeite.
Und das war auch das, was ich früher auch schon in den alten Beschleunigern
gesucht habe, weil das ist was faszinierendes.
Also ich erwähnte ja schon, die Physiker hier, wir kennen das,
wir träumen, wenn wir oben in den Himmel gucken und dieses Weltall funktionieren sehen.
Und dann brennen sich einem natürlich jetzt die Fotos und von irgendwelchen
Teleskopen ins Hirn, die uns zum Beispiel Bullet Galaxy zeigen,
wo zwei Galaxien miteinander kollidieren.
Und dann gibt es Fotografien von verschiedenen Teleskopen und Kameras in der Astronomie,
die uns dann zeigen, hier, dann gibt es den heißen Bereich,
die durchdringen sich schnell, aber dann, die durchdringen sich und dann gibt
es aber auch einen Bereich, den man mit Gravitationslinsen gemessen hat,
der geht schnell durch, das ist ein ganz klarer Beweis dafür,
dass es dunkle Materie geben muss im Weltall.
Und wenn es dunkle Materie geben muss, dann muss die auch beim Urknall entstanden sein.
Und welche Geräte eignen sich dann wieder besser als unsere hier,
wo wir in der Zeit zurückreisen können, ganz nah an den Urknall,
um zu gucken, hey, wenn es die dunkle Materie vom Urknall her gibt,
dann sind wir vielleicht jetzt in der richtigen Energie, beziehungsweise in
der richtigen Zeit zurück, in der wir gucken können, wie diese dunkle Materie entstanden ist.
Das heißt, wenn ich die in meinen Kameras nachweise, dann weiß ich endlich,
was das ist und das versuche ich.
Es gibt ja sehr viele Thesen, also dunkle Materie, um es auch nochmal kurz erläutert
zu haben, ist sozusagen das, was man halt bei der Beobachtung von Galaxien sich
quasi errechnet hat, was eigentlich noch da sein müsste, aber man...
Sieht's nicht. Hence the name Dunkel, aber es geht gar nicht so sehr um die
Dunkelheit, sondern eher darum, dass man es eigentlich nicht weiß.
Dark im Sinne von wir haben keine wirklich gute Erklärung dafür und auch der
Begriff Materie ist ja im Prinzip auch erstmal nur so daher gesagt,
weil ob es sich wirklich um Materie im eigentlichen Sinne oder zumindest im
aktuellen Verständnis davon was es sich,
Man kann es nicht mit Bestimmtheit sagen und es gibt ja auch viele Theorien,
die versuchen dieses Phänomen auf eine andere Art und Weise zu erklären.
Entweder indem man einfach so die Gravitation anders definiert,
rechnet einfach gar nicht richtig, ist ein bisschen schwierig gegen Einstein
zu arbeiten, aber man kann es ja mal probieren.
Oder ja, dass alles voll ist mit irgendwie schwarzen Löchern und man es nur
deshalb nicht beobachten kann,
weil man halt einfach den Elektromagnetismus sozusagen fernhält und keinerlei
Photon mehr entweichen kann, was ja nun unser primäres Messinstrument eben ist.
Es sei denn man benutzt halt jetzt noch Gravitationswellenastronomie und Neutrinoastronomie,
die jetzt sozusagen frisch dazugekommen ist, aber das hilft uns in dem Fall
auch erstmal nicht weiter oder zumindest macht es derzeit so den Eindruck,
als ob man das nicht unbedingt weiterbringen kann.
Also hat man jetzt irgendwie das Problem, dass man eigentlich erstmal versucht
irgendwas nachzuweisen, von dem man noch nicht mal genau weiß, was es ist.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist ja jetzt die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass es sich doch um irgendeine Materieform handelt und damit ja sozusagen,
Teilchen haben muss, die irgendwelche Eigenschaften haben, ist jetzt auch nicht
komplett von der Hand zu weisen.
Das kann halt auch gut sein und die ganze Teilchenbeobachtung,
die halt jetzt über Jahrzehnte gemacht wurde, fast, ich weiß nicht wie lange
guckt man sich jetzt Teilchen an, 100 Jahre sind noch nicht ganz voll so,
aber da ging es dann irgendwie los.
Und natürlich jetzt vor allem so in den letzten 50,
60 Jahren mit den ganzen Beschleunigungsringen und eben der ganzen Teilchenphysik,
die hier auch theoretisch geleistet wird, kommt man eben so langsam an diesen
Punkt, dass man sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt hier so unser Standardmodell so ein bisschen zusammen.
Also alles das, was wir so bisher sehen konnten,
messen konnten, haben wir, wo wir auch theoretische Konstrukte drumherum gebaut haben,
um da sozusagen Verständnis zu bekommen, wie das auch alles miteinander interagiert,
ist so jetzt auch erstmal weitgehend komplett, nachdem halt dieses Higgs-Feld und bzw.
Das Teilchen, was daraus resultiert, das Higgs-Boson, dann auch erfolgreich am CERN gemessen wurde.
Und wenn man jetzt also sagt, jetzt brauchen wir aber noch dunkle Materie,
dann müssen wir halt irgendwo gucken, wo wir noch nicht geguckt haben und das
kann halt bedeuten, entweder haben wir noch nicht scharf genug geguckt.
Oder wir gucken in einem falschen Bereich und brauchen noch mehr Power.
Zum Beispiel? Ja richtig.
Und gibt es noch einen anderen Ansatz wohin man jetzt guckt?
Du fasst das sehr richtig zusammen und sehr schön auch. Weil es in der Tat so ist.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen wir suchen da etwas wo wir eigentlich keine Idee haben.
Und deswegen ist das Schöne ja auch, wie viele Physiker verschiedene Ansätze
nehmen und die haben alle ihre gleiche Berechtigung.
Also da sieht man wieder, Wissenschaft löst sich oder geht nur,
wenn wir alle da zusammen uns die Sachen angucken.
Also Astronomie ist da ganz wichtig, weil vielleicht ist dunkle Materie wirklich
nicht so, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Die Beschleuniger, was wir hier machen,
bieten uns in einer Hinsicht halt vielleicht eine Möglichkeit.
Aber ob das die ist, um dann nachher dunkle Materie wirklich zu finden, das weiß ich nicht.
Jetzt haben wir halt diese fette Maschine, jetzt kann man ja auch zumindest mal versuchen was geht.
Genau und das ist das Argument, was ich eben meinte. Wenn man dann annimmt,
dunkle Materie sind Teilchen, die beim Urknall entstanden sind,
weil irgendwann müssen sie ja entstanden sein, Dann hilft mir diese Maschine,
die ja nichts anderes ist als eine Zeitmaschine und Bedingungen des frühen Weltalls,
10hoch-12 Sekunden nach dem Urknall, uns beobachten lässt.
Und wenn ich da dann gucke, wurden da vielleicht dunkle Materieteilchen erzeugt,
dann habe ich ja vielleicht Glück gehabt.
Vielleicht reicht auch die Energie nicht, vielleicht müsste ich auch noch weiter
zurückgehen, 10hoch-13, 10hoch-14.
Das würde uns natürlich in der Teilchenphysik oder in der beschleunigerbasierten
Teilchenphysik wieder helfen zu sagen wir bauen den nächsten Beschleuniger.
Die Pläne gibt es ja im Prinzip, man ist zumindest auf der Reise mit diesem
FCEE hier zumindest erstmal in der Planungsphase.
Aber da wollen wir jetzt gar nicht weiter.
Also das ist sozusagen etwas, was jetzt noch...
Unklar ist wann es wie in welcher Form konkret kommen wird und dann selbst wenn
es beschlossen ist auch noch eine Weile dauert, weil bis man 190 oder 100 Kilometer
reingebaut hat, so einen Tunnel muss man erstmal gegraben bekommen.
Die andere Methode ist natürlich das zu verbessern was man schon hat und dann
sind wir ja im Prinzip wieder genau in deinem Feld. Dann kommt es ja sozusagen
darüber an, okay vielleicht müssen wir einfach nur besser detektieren.
Alexander Ruschauer hat natürlich von der Beschleunigerseite her auch ja schon erzählt,
was Sie als Team dazu beitragen können, indem Sie dann diese Dichten in dieser
Pakete verbessern, also quasi
die Qualität des Urmaterials, auf dem man kollidieren lässt, verbessert.
Aber was ist jetzt sozusagen eure Perspektive im Sinne von was kann man an diesen
Detektoren noch verbessern?
Da gehen wir jetzt mal von unlimitierten finanziellen Möglichkeiten aus.
Wenn man schon träumt dann richtig.
Was würdest du dann sozusagen ranschaffen?
Tatsächlich sind unsere Beschleuniger Kollegen immens wichtig.
Und zwar ist es ja so, dunkle Materie scheint es ja im Beschleuniger nicht in
großen Mengen zu geben. Sonst hätten wir bestimmt schon was gesehen,
Fotos davon gesehen können.
Das heißt, was müssen uns die Kollegen von den Beschleunigern zur Verfügung
stellen, ist eigentlich so, bleiben wir mal bei dem Bild, was ich vorher schon
hatte, das ist so wie wenn man die Regeln von Fußball nicht kennt.
Wenn man sich viele Fotos anguckt, lernt man langsam was über die Regeln von
Fußball kennen und einmal Maradona den Ball mit der Hand spielen sehen,
da muss man schon eine Menge Fotos durchgehen, um das dann zu sehen.
Und jetzt nehmen wir mal an, dunkle Materie ist halt wirklich so selten,
entsteht die bei den Kollisionen, das heißt wir müssen unwahrscheinlich viele
Fotos machen, das heißt wir brauchen eine Art Zeit.
B und das liefern uns tatsächlich die Beschleuniger, sind so dichte Teilchenpakete,
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Protonen sich treffen höher ist.
Das heißt, dass wir mehr Bilder haben, bei denen das überhaupt hätte entstehen
können. Das heißt eigentlich sagen wir Intensität, wir brauchen mehr Daten und
mehr Fotos. Zeit hilft uns.
Handgottes, wir sind immer wieder beim Gottesdanken.
Ne das bitte nicht, das ist ein sehr unglücklicher Name.
Aber Maradona und Handgottes können wir doch mal bitte, den können wir so lassen glaube ich.
Also das, da helfen die uns tatsächlich. Also wir brauchen Intensität und wir
brauchen Möglichkeiten von diesen 40 Millionen Bildungen pro Sekunde wirklich
auch alle analysieren zu können.
Das heißt moderne Computertechnologie, moderne Elektronik, schnelle Elektronik.
Die Atlasrate erhöhen so würde man sagen.
Richtig genau. Das ist das was wir auch machen im Moment.
Da bauen wir unsere Detektoren noch weiter aus, verbessern die,
weil klar Atlas wurde 2012 angeschaltet oder 2008 angeschaltet,
das ist ja 2008 angeschaltet, das ist ja schon alte Technologie.
Jetzt wollen wir wieder modernere Sachen da reinbringen, um die Raten noch weiter
zu erhöhen, die Anzahl der Fotos und vor allem die Kapazität diese Fotos genau zu analysieren.
Weil wie sähe eigentlich dunkle Materie aus auf einem Foto?
Das ist ja, das sagtest du eben auch schon so schön, man sieht ja nix. Es ist genau das,
dass man eben nichts sieht, also nicht ganz, aber wenn solche Teilchen zusammenstoßen,
Dann fliegen ja alle möglichen Teilchen in irgendwelche Richtungen und werden
da von den Kameras vermessen.
Und damit haben wir dann im Prinzip Energie und Impuls aller Teilchen, die da wegfliegen.
Wenn wir jetzt was haben, was man nicht sieht, dann fehlt irgendwo an der Stelle
was. Dann ist irgendwas nicht mehr richtig ausbalanciert. vor allem.
In einem Bereich, der senkrecht zum Strahlverlauf geht. Und das muss man sich ja so vorstellen.
Wenn Teilchen zusammenprallen, haben die ja Flugrichtung. Und diese Flugrichtung
sind ja nur entlang des Strahlrohrs.
Wenn wir jetzt ein Foto machen von den wegfliegenden Teilchen,
dann muss ja, weil bisher keinerlei Bewegungsrichtung transvers zu diesem oder
senkrecht auf diesen Strahlaxen war, Man muss ja auf dem Bild alles balanciert
sein, was transvers davon weg geht.
Das heißt, wenn was in die eine Richtung geht, muss auch was in die andere Richtung
gehen, damit es in der Summe wieder Impulsehaltung gilt.
Ja, ich hoffe, du kannst noch ein bisschen folgen.
Ich kann folgen, ja.
Super. Und dafür ist es dann so, wenn jetzt dabei ein dunkles Materieteilchen
entstanden wäre, dann fliegt das in eine Richtung, wird aber überhaupt nicht vermessen.
Aber es wird natürlich von irgendwas balanciert, was sagen wir mal ein Teilchenstrahl
ist oder ein Jet ist und so, der in diese Richtung geht.
Und wenn wir uns dann die Bilder angucken und nur diese transverse Ebene senkrecht
zum Strahl uns angucken, dann sieht man plötzlich etwas, das nennen wir fehlende Energie.
Missing Energy. Weil da dann unser Detektor nichts gesehen hat.
Aber kann es nicht sein, dass wenn es in eine Richtung dunkle Materie geht,
dass es auch in die andere Richtung dunkle Materie geht?
Das kann natürlich auch sein. Dunkle Materie wird dann farbproduziert aber...
Kann aber, also es ist durchaus wahrscheinlich, die Teilchen sind immer unterschiedlich sozusagen.
Es gibt relativ wenig Symmetrie in diesem Ergebnis.
Ja aber es kann durchaus sein, dass dann so ein Bild ist und das ist genau das
worauf wir dann achten. Es kann natürlich auch ein Neutrino sein,
weil ein Neutrino macht genau diese selbe Signatur.
Aber da ein Neutrino leicht ist, fällt das nicht so auf als Missing Energy,
so ein schweres dunkle Materieteil, das wäre richtig schwer,
das müsste echt schon ganz schön doll ausbalanciert werden und das würde sehr
viel fehlen in der Energie machen.
Also das sind so, wie wir dann in den Fotos solche Dinge erkennen könnten und
deswegen brauchen wir halt viele.
Also Abtastrate erhöhen hat ja auch, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
die eigentliche Bauform und die Komponenten, die ganzen Messkomponenten,
die widersprechen einer höheren Abtastrate nicht.
Man muss es halt einfach nur konsumieren können. Das heißt es ist eine Frage
der Computertechnik, der Datenübertragung, der Speicherung etc.
Der Echtzeitanalyse der Daten um das entsprechend rausfiltern zu können was
relevant ist und was nicht relevant ist.
Und das skaliert ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen mit der technologischen Entwicklung der Elektronik.
Das hat zwar auch nochmal so seine Probleme aber im Prinzip tut sich da ja noch was.
Das ist genau richtig, jaja.
Dieses Steinhandmodell ist ja irgendwie ein bisschen kompliziert,
wenn man drauf schaut und ich hab langsam das Gefühl es sickert bei mir ein bisschen ein,
aber es gibt ja dann noch so diese Idee in dem Erklärungsversuch von allem mit der Supersymmetrie.
Auch noch so ein catchy Abkürzungsnamen, Susi.
Und mir ist nicht so ganz klar wie populär diese Theorie eigentlich so ist,
also ob das eher so eine Fringe Meinung ist und alle schütteln so ein bisschen
mit dem Kopf, aber schauen wir mal.
Oder ob das schon irgendwie auch so ein heißer Kandidat zu sein scheint,
weil es scheint ja bisher noch nicht wirklich auch nur einen Beleg dafür zu
geben, sondern es ist sozusagen so eine Theorie. Und die macht ja dann dieses
ganze Standardmodell nochmal komplizierter, weil es ja alles auch nochmal doppelt gibt.
Ich hab nicht so ganz verstanden, warum das eigentlich, wenn man überhaupt auf die Idee kommt,
dass das irgendwie sein könnte und was es dann irgendwie leichter macht zu erklären
als jetzt schon und geschweige denn,
wie man jetzt in irgendeiner Form mit diesen Teilchendetektoren und dem ganzen
Messzoo, den wir hier haben, da weitere Erkenntnisse einsammeln kann.
Also erstmal Supersymmetrie ist tatsächlich nicht tot zu kriegen.
Es ist auch ein tolles Physikmodell, was viele Vorteile hat.
Also versuche ich mal auf Folgendes einzugehen. Also wenn man vom Standardmodell
guckt, wir haben zwei verschiedene Teilchentypen.
Ganz wichtig. Das eine sind nämlich Materieteilchen. Das sind so die Legosteine,
weil es denen alles aufgebaut ist. Und dann gibt es die Kraftteilchen.
Das sind so die großen Unterschiede und Bereiche, die es gibt.
Genau. Also das eine sind so Hadronen und Leptonen.
Also das eine macht so die Kerne
unter anderem. Das andere macht so die Elektronen und die Verwandten.
Und das andere sind die, die sozusagen die Kräfte übertragen.
Licht, das ist das Photon, elektromagnetische Kraft.
Gluon ist die Kraft, die im Prinzip die Quarks in einem Kern zusammenhält.
Dann gibt es natürlich die Gravitation, kennen wir auch alle.
Da gibt es aber noch nicht so das gefundene Graviton dazu, haben wir noch nicht
gesehen. Aber was wir natürlich kennen, das ist das sogenannte Überträger der
schwachen Kraft. Ich nenne es immer die Harry Potter Teilchen.
Und zwar ist die schwache Kraft ja nichts anderes als die Protonteilchen,
weil die sind dafür verantwortlich, dass ein Teilchen sich in was anderes umwandeln
kann, das ist ganz wichtig, also sehr fundamental.
Wir kennen doch alle den radioaktiven Zerfall. Was passiert ist,
dass ein Proton sich in Neutronen oder andersrum umwandeln kann und das klappt
einfach nur, weil es diese schwache Kraft gibt. Ja, der wird dann zum Beispiel ein...
Über ein Z-Boson, das elektrisch neutral ist, kann sich ein Teilchen umwandeln
oder über ein W-Boson, was auch geladen sein kann, kann sich ein Teilchen mit
einer anderen Ladung umwandeln.
Deswegen, das ist immer so als die Harry Potter Kraft, dann vergisst man das
nicht mehr, warum das so ist.
Also wir haben diese beiden Gruppen, ich nenne es immer so die Ist und die Wird Abteilung.
Das eine ist irgendwie, das andere sorgt dafür, dass irgendwas wird.
Genau, nee das ist auch richtig. Und jetzt ist es so,
wenn man in der Theorie, Theoretiker Massen von Teilchen berechnen,
dann ist das ja nicht einfach nur eine Zahl,
sondern zu der Masse eines Teilchens in seiner Berechnung trägt zum Beispiel
bei sogenannte Schleifenrechnung,
dass aus dem Vakuum irgendwelche Koppelungen gibt, die dann noch zu der Masse
eines Teilchens beitragen.
Da wäre ich jetzt manchmal, das ist, hätte ich gerne jetzt ein Bild,
was ich zeigen würde, dann würde man es natürlich besser verstehen.
Aber die müssen wir erzeugen.
Aber wenn man damit zum Beispiel auf diese Art, auch der Schleifenberechnung,
die Higgs-Masse berechnet mit der modernen Theorie, dann stellt man plötzlich
fest, weil wenn man sich die Higgs-Masse bei hohen Energien anguckt,
dann wird die plötzlich unendlich groß.
Das beobachtet man ja gar nicht, sondern die verändert sich ja gar nicht so.
Und daraufhin gibt es dann halt diese Supersymmetrie, eine Theorie,
die halt sagt, ah, weil zu der Masse eines Teilchens in den Schleifen tragen
die Kraftteilchen mit einem anderen Vorzeichen bei als die Materieteilchen.
Und jetzt kommt der Trick, wenn man dann halt sagt, ja gut, jetzt gibt es noch
supersymmetrische Teilchen zu den Kraftteilchen,
das sind nämlich supersymmetrische Materieteilchen und zu den Materieteilchen,
also supersymmetrische Kraftteilchen, dann hat man plötzlich zwar die Anzahl
der Schleifen verdoppelt, aber dadurch, dass die sich von den Vorzeichen her
unterscheiden, Kompensieren die sich und damit erreicht man in der Theorie plötzlich,
dass die Massen nicht explodieren.
So ein mathematisches Modell, was dann diese Sonderfälle erläutert.
So startet das und das tolle dabei war und deswegen wurde es so populär,
weil das erklärt dann solche Phänomene wie dunkle Materie, weil falls es solche
supersymmetrischen Teilchen gäbe, dann existieren neutrale, schwere, stabile Teilchen.
Und das wären super dunkle Materie Kandidaten.
Ah verstehe, ok. Das macht alle so scharf drauf.
Genau und tatsächlich bin ich auch scharf auf Susi.
Deswegen, falls es die gibt.
Hoffe ich halt immer noch. Ich kann jetzt genügend Bilder analysieren von meinem
Detektor, um dann endlich mal so ein dunkles Materieteilchen zu finden.
Also es ist noch eine Menge Musik drin sowohl was jetzt potenzielle Dinge die
es zu entdecken gilt betrifft.
Klar theoretisch ist das ja auch eine unendliche Liste an Erkenntnissen die man da haben kann.
Aber es ist auch, sagen wir mal, nicht unwahrscheinlich,
dass die ganze Technologie, die jetzt hier am CERN so über die Jahrzehnte zusammengebaut wurde,
im Prinzip auch noch eine ganze Menge liefern kann,
weil es einfach sehr viel Optimierungspotenzial gibt und weil auch irgendwie
absehbar ist, dass man sozusagen mit dieser Art und Weise der Forschung schon
den Ding noch mächtig auf den Busch klopfen kann.
Man ist ja nicht so auf einmal Higgs Boson ist gefunden, wir können das ja abbauen,
sondern da geht wahrscheinlich noch was. Das ist ja auch schon mal eine interessante Erkenntnis.
Tatsächlich, es gibt ja gemeinsame Rätsel, die uns auch mit der Kosmologie völlig zusammenbringen.
Das ist ja auch zum Beispiel dunkle Energie, was ist das? Ich finde das immer
noch wahnsinnig, wenn man sich
vorstellt, dass unser Universum immer schneller in der Ausdehnung wird.
Eigentlich ist das verrückt. Das heißt, es muss irgendwas ziehen und irgendwas drücken. Was ist das?
Und selbst da ist es so, dass wir bei uns in der Teilchenphysik,
wenn irgendwie die Ursache für solche Effekte darin liegt, dass es irgendetwas
gibt, was auch beim Urknall erzeugt
worden ist, dann haben wir hier eine Chance, diese Sachen zu sehen.
Und wir gucken halt auch nach dem völlig Unerwarteten. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir,
Jetzt nur nach bestimmten Modellen suchen. Wir machen natürlich auch unsere
Fotos, gucken uns auch so an, vielleicht gibt's ja dreibeinige Hunde oder sowas.
Was ich aber immer interessant, also was ich wirklich jetzt interessant finde
nach all diesen ganzen Gesprächen ist,
kommt alles zur Sprache, aber das Ding mit der Schwerkraft mal schlüssig zu
erklären, das traut sich keiner auch nur in den Mund zu nehmen.
Warum ist das so ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln, da will keiner drüber reden.
Ist das irgendwie allen peinlich, dass es da noch nicht mal ein gutes Erklärungsmuster
gibt, wie es eigentlich wirkt.
Ich meine wir kennen die Effekte und Einstein hat alles gut beschrieben
und nachvollziehbar und seit 100 Jahren wird alles getestet und rumexperimentiert
und er hat immer noch recht und wir können so ein Stück Metall 30 Jahre durchs
All schicken Und es kommt dann wirklich genau da an, wo wir es gerne hätten.
Allein nur mit diesen Formeln.
Trotzdem gibt es keine gute Erklärung, was jetzt wirkt.
Und wir haben ja in diesem Standardmodell viel Wirkstoff drin und das lässt
sich bei der schwachen und bei der starken Energie und vor allem bei der elektromagnetischen Kraft,
wie hier ja auch festgestellt wurde, haben die ja auch alle so einen Bezug zueinander,
die haben alle was miteinander zu tun,
also die starke Kraft scheint auch noch so ein bisschen isoliert dazustehen,
aber die Gravitation ist halt überhaupt nicht beschrieben und diese Idee eines
Gravitons ist ja auch nur so ein dahergesagter Name,
also es gibt keinerlei Indizien, dass es sowas gibt, will sich da keiner drum kümmern?
Ich glaube da würden sich liebend gerne viele drum kümmern.
Ich möchte auch gerne ein bisschen so anfangen. Ich gehe jetzt ein bisschen
von mir aus. Du fragst hier einen Experimentator.
Ich bin Experimentalphysiker und kein Theoretiker.
Also da könnten sicher...
Versuchen nur die Diskussion in der Wissenschaftsgemeinde abzubilden.
Aber da sind mir meine Kollegen von der Theorie um so vieles voraus und wahrscheinlich
auch bessere Gesprächspartner als ich da zu dem Thema der Gravitation bin.
Aber und das finde ich wahrscheinlich auch so interessant nachzusuchen was eigentlich
um die Zeit des Urknalls passiert ist,
weil wir wissen ja gar nicht ob die Kräfte die wir bisher beschrieben haben,
diese vier, Gravitation, elektromagnetische Kraft, schwache Kraft,
starke Kraft, ob das überhaupt alle Kräfte sind.
Und ob Gravitation überhaupt eine ist.
Und ob das überhaupt eine ist. Na gut, also Szeno 35 mal schwächer,
zumindest so beobachtet man das und so fassen wir das jetzt als elektromagnetische
Kraft. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch was völlig anderes.
Vielleicht könnten natürlich auch unsere Experimente darüber was bringen,
aber ich denke mir manchmal, wir sind so als Menschen doch relativ blind.
Also wir haben ein paar Sinne, aber das heißt ja nicht nur, weil wir irgendwelche
Sachen nicht mit unseren eigenen Sinnen oder sogar jetzt mit unseren Kameras
bemerken können, dass es diese Dinge nicht gibt.
Ich meine, vielleicht gibt es ja noch andere Kräfte, die uns erlauben zu wechselwirken.
Diese Konsequenzen, Paralleluniversen etc. sind plötzlich riesig und machen
Spaß darüber nachzudenken.
Auf jeden Fall habt ihr eine Menge Spaß hier, das merkt man schon.
Ja, was möchtest du dem Gesagten noch anstellen, was noch unerwähnt geblieben
ist, was du den Hörern vielleicht noch mit auf die Reise geben möchtest?
Also auf jeden Fall würde ich sagen, kommt mal zum CERN und guckt euch das an.
Also diese Möglichkeit, es gibt hier Besuche und so alles, aber auch diese Atmosphäre
mal aufzuschnuppern, zu sehen, die Experimentierhallen, Also das haut eigentlich jeden um.
Kann ich nur jedem raten, versuch das mal. Kommt mal zu uns her.
Gibt es eine Webseite, kann man Besuche machen und da sind ziemlich viele Leute.
Ja die schiere Größe allein des Wissenschaftsstandorts ist ja schon ziemlich bemerkenswert.
Und studiert Physik, kann ich auch immer so sagen.
Alright, gut, dann vielen Dank Christoph für die Ausführungen über den Detektor,
Atlas und natürlich auch alle anderen Aspekte, die wir hier besprochen haben.
Das war jetzt die vorletzte Sendung hier vom CERN in dieser Reihe,
das heißt einen haben wir noch und da könnt ihr mal drauf warten, was dann noch kommt.
Ich sag vielen Dank und vielen Dank für's Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit.
Das war's für heute. Ich sag tschüss, bis bald.